[TYPEWRITER NOISES]
RETO MEIER: Hello, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, and
Welcome to This Week in
Android Development,
October 22nd, 2012.
If you've ever wondered what
happens when you combine a
love of Android with an
appreciation for fine grilled
meats, you are probably one of
the hundreds of Android meat
lovers to descend on Hurst,
Texas, for the Big Android
Barbecue last weekend.
Meanwhile in Germany, DevFest
Berlin was in full swing last
week, with one highlight being
the impromptu Android Design
in Action session held at Sybase
hosted by Nick Butcher
and special guest designer
Marie Schweiz.
While Nick was enjoying the
wurst and beer of Germany,
Rich [INAUDIBLE] was in Italy
enjoying pasta, pizza and
presenting at the
Firenze DevFest.
You can meet both Nick and Rich
this week at DroidCon
London, the annual celebration
of all things Android in the
beating heart of old
London town.
It was also a big week for the
Googleplay team, with the
launch of sales support in
India, which is now the
fourth-largest market for
app downloads worldwide.
They also launched the new
sleeker, faster, and easy to
navigate Android Developer
Console, details for which can
be found on the Android
Developer blog.
To celebrate the big week, you
can join the Developer Console
team for a special hangout on
Monday, 12 PM, London time,
should you be in possession of
a functional time machine.
Had the App Clinic been in
possession of such a device,
we could have avoided the string
of failures that have
plagued our broadcasts
in recent weeks.
As the Google founders have
instead chosen to invest their
discretionary budget in
self-driving cars and wearable
computers, we had to
rely on alternative
techniques for success.
We did so in style last week,
successfully broadcasting not
one, but two App Clinics,
starting with the long-awaited
Video Player app clinic, only
one day later than promised,
on Wednesday morning.
Having wisely chosen not to
rely on our success, Nick,
Roman and Adam's Android Design
in Action completed the
design for a hypothetical
video player.
Then on Friday, Ian and I were
back at it, reviewing
shopping list apps.
Tune in this Tuesday, as the
Design in Action team present
their take on Out of Milk
and Grocery IQ.
It turns out that there may
still be a rich market for
developers of pumpkin carving
and candy cataloging apps, so
this week we'll be announcing
some exciting changes to
future app clinic broadcasts,
rather than trying to review
non-existent Halloween apps.
In the meantime, use this Trello
board to nominate the
app and app categories
you'd like us to
review in future weeks.
In other Android Developer live
broadcasts this week, Dan
will be back again for the
Friday games review.
And our regular office hours
will be broadcast from London,
Mountain View, and Brazil, where
Bruno will once again be
dispensing what I can only hope
is Android development
knowledge in Portuguese.
If This Week in Android doesn't
offer you a rich
enough variety of Australian
accents, tune in to
[INAUDIBLE]'s weekly ADL Plus.
Last week he covered
notifications, and this week
he'll have more details on the
ADL Plus experiments with
connectivity API's.
In new Android documentation
this week, the notifications
API guide has received an
update to include rich
notifications.
As always, we look forward to
you joining us for our many
live shows, the schedule of
which you can find at Google
Developers Live.
Today's live wallpaper
was Galactic Core
from Kittehface Software.
And remember, missing you
is dark gray all alone.
My name is Reto Meier.
Thanks for watching.